[Musique]
tout au long du mois de mai le conseil
départemental des jeunes célèbrent
l'europe
une façon de comprendre l'importance des
investissements européens pour le
développement du territoire et plus
particulièrement au sein du monde
agricole le principal dispositif le
feader fonds européen agricole pour le
développement rural
le service ferder nous a sollicités pour
le joli mois de l'europe joli mois de
mai concernant les subventions fédère
donc ils nous ont sollicités pour
pouvoir travailler collaborer avec eux
avec le conseil départemental des jeunes
et aujourd'hui on est à saint pierre on
a été au campus pro et cet après midi on
est sur l'action sur l'armée flore pour
une visite qu'ont découverte des
différentes plantes médicinales donc
c'est vrai que là pour les jeunes ça
leur permet de connaître un petit peu
aussi la formation les métiers là des
cultures les plans les conseillers des
commissions sud et ouest visite les
installations de l'association
réunionnaise pour la modernisation de
l'économie fruitière légumière et
horticole un centre de recherche financé
par des fonds européens
ici on est vraiment dans une sur une
base une base d'experts
d'expérimentation avec des personnes
qualifiées qui viennent apporter des
solutions techniques à nos agriculteurs
et qui viennent aussi développer des
nouvelles variétés qui une fois qu'elles
auront fait leur l'heure je dirais leur
durée ici dans les pépinières pourront
être transportés chez l'agriculteur pour
que ces nouvelles variétés puisse se
développer en plein champ ou sous serre
aujourd'hui nous avons pu comprendre
l'importance des fonds qui étaient
donnés par l'europe notamment au mieux
de l'agriculture parce que on nous
expliquait clairement que l'europe se
défont et que cet argent il fallait
savoir l'exploiter et quoi faire avec et
c'est vrai qu'au niveau de l'agriculture
réunionnaise
nous avons quoi faire avec cet argent
ces jeunes conseillers départementaux
comprennent l'importance des
financements européens dans la
modernisation et le développement du
monde rural à la réunion le département
est au coeur du dispositif feader en
effet la collectivité a autorité de
gestion pour ces fonds sur le territoire
[Musique]